[Música]
y volvemos a hablar de economía en
directo américa de francés 24 luis
méndez uriso vamos a iniciar en reino
unido donde expertos advierten sobre los
subsidios del gobierno para evitar un
mayor impacto en los ciudadanos por el
precio de la energía hacia raúl de
acuerdo con el instituto de estudios
fiscales del reino unido- el gobierno
necesitaría destinar unos 14.500
millones de dólares adicionales para
mantener la escala de apoyo prometida
para ayudar a las familias a hacer
frente a la crisis del costo de vida a
medida que los precios de la energía
continúan en aumento el organismo señala
que el gobierno necesitaría duplicar la
subvención actual para los solicitantes
de beneficios en edad laboral y para
ayudar a los jubilados en medio de la
situación los laboristas anuncian un
plan para congelar el tope del precio de
la energía con un impuesto sobre las
ganancias extraordinarias
pero todo ello se presenta en medio de
la carrera para la elección de un nuevo
primer ministro y louis seguimos en
europa porque en alemania se dio a
conocer el valor de la tasa por el gas y
es que de acuerdo con trading job
citado por la agencia de noticias
reuters el valor de esta tasa será de
2.4 céntimos de euro por kilowatio hora
ésta pretende entrar en vigor a partir
del mes de octubre y forma parte de los
esfuerzos para distribuir los altos
costos de reemplazar el gas ruso entre
todos los consumidores finales para una
familia medida de cuatro personas esto
supondrá unos costos adicionales de al
menos
480 euros en el año bueno y nos venimos
a nuestra región nos vamos a argentina
porque en esa nación un estudio reveló
cambios en los patrones de consumo
debido a la altísima inflación que sufre
ese país así fue una publicación
registrada por clarín en el día domingo
estábamos hablando del día de ayer en la
misma se observa que tras una inflación
que alcanzó los 7,4 puntos porcentuales
en el mes de julio la mayor dentro de
los últimos 20 años alrededor de un 80
por ciento de los consultados en el
estudio reveló cambios en su manera de
comprar pero que están buscando ellos
están buscando más ofertas están
buscando segundas marcas o están
restringiendo las compras para evitar un
alto impacto en los precios nos vamos
hasta hacia el bid es porque el
presidente de corea del seguro anunció
un respaldo corea del norte a cambio de
la desnuclearización de ese país el
mandatario anunció que este movimiento
significaría una audacia iniciativa que
mejorará significativamente la economía
norcoreana la propuesta llega luego de
que
corea del norte amenazara con eliminar a
las autoridades de seguros por un
reciente brote de kobe 19 y a menos de
un mes después de que el líder kim
jong-un dijera que su país está listo
para movilizar su armamento nuclear en
una guerra contra eeuu y corea del sur
yon calificó la desnuclearización como
esencial para alcanzar la paz de la dura
duradera en la península coreana y
detalló un extenso plan de ayuda que
incluiría alimentos energía y también
apoyo para modernizar puertos
aeropuertos y hospitales escuchemos
la desnuclearización de corea del norte
es esencial para la paz sostenible en la
península de corea en el norte de asia
el mundo implementaremos un programa de
alimentos a gran escala brindaremos
asistencia para la infraestructura de
generación transmisión y distribución de
energía y llevaremos a cabo proyectos
para modernizar puertos y aeropuertos
para el comercio internacional
y nos vamos o elvis hasta afganistán
donde se cumple un año del regreso de
los talibanes del poder así es raúl una
situación que ha profundizado la crisis
económica en ese país que antes de la
llegada del talibán no era la mejor en
parte por haber estado mucho tiempo bajo
un conflicto y de acuerdo con algunos
medios y especialistas en ese país la
corrupción del gobierno que salió que a
aquel entonces está apoyado por naciones
occidentales también afectó la situación
del deterioro ha sido tal en la economía
que diversos organismos han alertado
sobre ello uno de los aspectos de la
llegada al poder del talibán es la
limitación hacia la mujer para que pueda
trabajar o estudiar ellos de acuerdo con
la unicef él ha llevado a que el país
pierda alrededor de 500 millones de
dólares en el último año por no permitir
que las niñas y estudiando estos
representa según el estudio un 25 por
ciento de su producto interno bruto y
agrega el informe que de permitir que 3
millones de niñas actualmente en edad de
educación secundaria accedan al mercado
laboral podrían aportar una cifra que
alcanza los 5 mil 400 millones de
dólares pero estamos hablando que para
enero de este año al menos 500 millones
de personas habían sido expulsadas o
habían perdido pero a unas 500 mil
personas habían sido expulsadas todavía
perdido sus empleos la organización
internacional del trabajo en dicho
periódico la tasa de desempleo en 16%
esto representa alrededor de 3 puntos
porcentuales por encima de la tasa anual
registrada en diciembre de 2021 la onu
proyecto en aquel entonces que la
pérdida de empleos podría alcanzar unos
900 mil puestos de trabajo para este
2022 por otro lado el banco mundial
revela que alrededor de 25 millones de
afganos es decir más de la mitad de la
población ha caído por debajo de la
línea de pobreza y la onu ha señalado
meses atrás a que al menos un 90 de la
población ha tenido problemas severos
para alimentarse allí en esa nación un
amplio porcentaje de los ciudadanos
solamente puede cubrir sus necesidades
básicas de alimentación y un 3% puede
cubrir todas las necesidades básicas
pero durante mucho tiempo las nuevas
autoridades del país han pedido el
regreso de unos 9000 millones de dólares
en fondos ubicados en el extranjero 7000
de ellos están en resguardo en
eeuu y otros 2.000 en europa los
recursos que resguarda eeuu la actual
administración de joe biden ha dispuesto
que la mitad serían para gastos
humanitarios y la otra mitad podrían ser
destinadas a la indemnización de
víctimas de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre cifra el diálisis tiene que
ver en este caso con la empresa es keith
incorporated de corea del sur que
anunció una inversión de 250 millones de
dólares en terra power una empresa
estadounidense fundada por bill gates
que desarrolla reactores de energía
nuclear de tamaño pequeño todo ello para
contribuir
para disminuir el uso de combustibles
fósiles para la producción de energía y
como siempre gracias por toda la
información económica de mañana nos
vemos por supuesto con más economía
pasamos a salvar a rodrigo sedano con
todos los deportes